oh my name is Amir popco I'm a software
engineer and data scientists at saluto
I've been here for the last seven years
and today I want to share our experience
with creating a system to monitor our
main KPIs
so a little interest to the specific
product that I'm talking about so this
product is mainly some kind of a tech
support where our customers are tons of
customers so before I have the ability
to ask questions any technical questions
and there is on the other side people
that we call experts
so there those are like the technicians
the supporters that they provide answers
for those questions so a customer is
starting with asking a question from his
app or specific app or web this question
is inserted into some kind of a pool of
questions and an expert can take a
question whenever an expert takes a
question then a session starts meaning a
session is an instance of instance of a
customer asking a question and an expert
answering the specific question so those
are the main entities that I'm going to
talk about further on customer expert
and a session experts of course they
have some kind of their own platform in
order to answer questions a few things
to note here
first our system is a synchronously
meaning we mainly talk about chat and
since this tech support is via chat then
an expert can answer multiple questions
at the same time and this is one second
of all we sort of shifted this to gig
economy style so most of our experts are
not actually workforce a little but they
just they are contractors of the KaBlam
same is uber so uber people who drive
for uber and not uber workers but they
are some kind of contractors so it's
basically the same where the pain model
is paid by session same as we're paying
by
right so that's a high-level entry to
the product I'm going to talk about we
have multiple products in saluto this is
the one we are currently talking about
questions cool so what we try to achieve
in this new system we created so every
product EV is kpi's meaning the key
performance indicators which he measure
is success in our case what we usually
measure is first the resolution rate and
star rating so what are those two
explicit questions that are triggered to
a customer at the end of a session first
asking him was your issue result yes or
no so it's a binomial response and the
second one is the star rating rate your
expert so this is like get taxi uber
stuff like this other KPIs we want to
monitor is the time to assign time from
when a customer asked is first question
until is getting the first response the
time to handle which is from this first
response how long it is until the issue
is resolved so we have a lot of
different high level KPIs which we
always want to monitor because they are
saying to us do we succeed as a product
or do we fail or are we staying at the
same spot so those are the KPIs in
addition of course we are making a lot
of changes to production every day and
each change in production may cause some
harm to those KPIs and that's mainly
what we want to be able to easily
monitor so when I'm saying we want to
monitor every change so usually what we
think about is something that is some
kind of a feature some kind of change in
the behavior but something I want to
note is it only it also applies for
bacon changes where we think we just
change it we changed a database and no
harm supposed to be done but we can
never take everything in account so
maybe the new database
caused some slowness that we haven't
measured and our main KPIs are getting
harmed etc so also it applies for
backend changes where you want to make
sure you are not harming any KPI trying
to avoid bias so whenever you are
developing a feature you have some kind
of intrinsic bias whether you're a data
scientist of software developer product
manager weeks designer you always have
some kind of like feeling like it's my
baby for the what you're developing and
when it comes to the point where you
need to measure what was the impact then
it can cause some bias so having a
system where everything is kind of flat
same test for all the experiment in the
same way against all the different KPIs
we want to measure so that is another
thing we wanted to achieve and another
important thing is an easy integration
to day to day in production meaning if
we will currently go to development team
and say you need to monitor all those
KPIs and you must do it after every
feature then they will say look it's a
lot of time we did we cannot do it it's
not efficient for us or we need more
resources in ours in order to do it
so another thing in mind was how we do
it as much automatically scan in order
to be efficient and heaven easy
integration to our day to day so it's
gonna the talk is gonna be splitted into
the part where I give the high level of
how we build it just like the main
modules and then we're talking about
different considerations we had along
the way for every experiment we want to
run so first part how do we collect the
data in order to run experiments so for
every change in production what we are
doing first we want to introduce the
change just to a portion of the users so
we have a system that was developed
in-house which is an open source called
tweak so it's a great feature management
tool highly
recommended and if you have later more
questions or you're interesting about a
future management tool feel free to ask
so we use this system in order to split
the data and then we can have the
control group and the test group so the
control group keeps getting the same
behavior as before where the test group
is getting the new behavior that we want
to experiment on and at this point comes
to the mainly the the only thing we ask
from the development team is we already
have analytic system in place all you
need to do is raise a custom event with
a few things in order for us to be able
to provide all these automatic
measurements for every experiment so
what we ask raise a specific event raise
the event in the point where you decide
whether to give the new or the oil
behavior and in this event put the
information like the experiment name the
whether it's control group or test group
and we talked about we have a few
different entities so we have so
sometimes we experiment over customers
when we change the customer application
and we want to experiment on it
sometimes we change the behavior of the
experts web and we experiment on it so
we have different entities where we can
experiment on each one then we also ask
for the identity so that's what you see
here I'm not sure if this okay so also
we are adding the identity so that's the
only thing we are asking from the
development part and then we have all
the data in the same place where all our
analytics resides and we can iterate on
every current running experiment and
test the control and test group against
all our different domain kpi's so we
specifically run the a/b test against
specific domain KPIs and later on report
the result which currently is by email
to the relevant people that
created the experiment so that's the
high level any questions so far so now
we are kind of avoiding this question
because we don't run too many
experiments when we get to the point
that there are tons of experiment and
they are bothering each other then I
think we are in a great spot where we
are very experimental iterating very
fast and then we will need to think of
how we do so we haven't got to those
issues when we get to those issues it
will be great
cool so I'll talk a little bit about
different considerations we had along
the way when creating the system like
the main things so everything a lot of
the things we done here was together
with a product manager since most of the
decisions here we want to make sure we
want monitor domain kpi's which is very
product oriented so you always want it
to be aligned and giving the data point
of view from our side and getting the
product point of view from their side
and then thinking together about what
will be best so for example considering
the product needs we have one of our
KPIs which is the time to assign how
much time from the first customer
questions until until he is getting his
first response so for this we can for
example go to what is the average time
but when we go there we know that we
have a long tail and we tend to have a
lot of outliers so is it a good metric
talking to the product and explaining
look if the average will change from one
minute the two minute it can mean maybe
that there is just one outlier that
takes everything to two minutes but it
might be also that we have all the
sessions waiting for another minute
which is the second one is much more
harmful for us than the first one so
those are different things we need to
consider
same to destroy ting we know that 85% of
our customers give five starts so just
looking at the average saying that
somebody that gave three is more than
somebody that gave two but we having a
hard time explaining how to is different
than three from two different customers
so for example here what we chose is
just to make it binomial whether the
customer gave five stars or not another
thing about the distribution of our KPIs
for example the time to handle the time
from the first response until the issue
is resolved so here we see we see the
distribution I'm not good with it sorry
okay so here we see the histogram of
distribution and we see their hours from
when the session started the first
question we have sessions that took 10
hours what does it mean an expert and a
customer actually chat for 10 hours
straight probably not so do we want to
monitor it just as average or do we want
to think of different use cases and try
to monitor those so that's about the
what to monitor part which brings up a
lot of different questions product twice
and data wise interesting questions so
this is actually because of a feature we
introduced if a customer stops
responding then we cannot just resolve
the issue we need to wait 24 hours and
ask him along the way are we still there
and just after 24 hours if you don't
respond we close the session so so the
distribution is impacted due to our
features so great question alright so
next consideration we have how long will
it take for an experiment to end
so sitting with product and for example
we thought about resolution rates the
resolution is the question was your
issue resolved yes no resolution rate is
the percent of sessions that are
resolved for this one we are saying okay
let's say we are currently at 70% we are
considering now what would be the
minimum detectable effect we want so
staying to the product what do we want
to be able to detect so starting from
all right let's be able to detect very
small changes if 70 change to 70 point
zero zero one I want to be able to
detect it but this using also a p-value
legitimate p-value of 0.05 which is the
false positive right then we get to all
right then if we want to be able to
detect this smaller effect we'll
probably need to wait years so what can
we do the next question is what is our
current sample collection rate if we
collect 100,000 samples per day or do we
collect 100 samples per day so in our
case we got to about 10 days of
experiment which gave us false positive
rate of 5% p-value of 0.05 with a
minimum detectable effect of about 2.5%
so of course we made some trade-offs
here but we can say to the teams we'll
get the results for your experiment in
one month or one year so that's the
trade-off we must take into account
somehow because the sample collection
rate is is just constant you can change
it and let's take us to the other point
so assuming we know that we need 10 days
to run an experiment after 10 days we
can run the statistical test we chose
and get a result but what if we let a
feature out and this feature changes the
resolution rate from 70% to 30% probably
we can know about it ahead and it's even
one of the purposes of the system to be
able to stop
early and said to raise a flag look we
are arming a KPI we must stop so how can
we try to find it earlier as early as
cannon stopped so taking the same test
we wanted to run in the tenth day and
just run it every day or multiple times
is not allowed statistic wise because
then what we actually do is we change
the p-value we thought we have so if we
thought about p-value of false positive
rate of 5% and then we run the same test
for 10 days every day what we are going
to get is about P value of 0.15 meaning
around 15% false positives and I'll try
to give some intuitions to this first if
we run the same statistical test
multiple times and we stop when we find
significance then running multiple
steins just increase our chances to get
significant by definition we don't have
anything to stop the other direction we
just say we'll stop the experiment when
we will get significant then so it's
already smells fishy and another thing I
found online which gave me some sense I
hope it will work here let's look just
at the above graph what we see here are
100 simulations of another potus's
running for 10 days and here we plotted
the z-scores so those are the z-scores
of about 0.05 5% false positive and
there are 10,000 samples a day for each
one of those hundred simulations so if
we look if we learn the statistical test
on day 10 at the end we will get about 5
simulations that went to the wrong sides
which are our false positives if we'll
take the same graph but we'll stop early
run the tests every single day then we
can see that all those that remain here
are those that are going to be our false
positive so even here we are getting to
around 12 simulations that are false
positive just because we ran the same
experiment
every day so for the question of how to
stop early but maintaining the p-value
we find the most simplest solution so
there are two here that are sort of the
same what they say if you want to have
some kind of P value let's say 0.05 and
you want to run the statistical test
three times meaning the amount of times
we run a statistical test here is
impacting our decision then we should
look for a different p-value when we run
it we want to run it three times then we
will look for different people you in
order to get this p-value another way
which is kind of the same is let's say
again we want to have to run the
statistical test three times with the
0.05 p-value then this method what it
says we can just change the p-values we
asked for of over time so the first time
we look at this z-score the second run
we look at this dead score and the third
time we look at this z-score so it's all
the same setting add the p-values you're
testing for and fixing the amount of
times you want to run the statistic test
so this is the method we chose which is
relatively easy to implement so easy for
our first iteration of the system we're
currently running our first iteration of
the system the system will probably
evolve over time pretty much less
consideration how much time do I have
left by the way sorry all right
so assuming we want to introduce some
kind of a new change to the expiry to
the expert side so the expert web we
want to iterate and try some experiment
over there we do know and we saw it we
backed up with data that different
experts tend to have different behavior
meaning they they are different with the
star rating they have they are different
with the resolution rate the time to
assign the amount of session each expert
take they pretty much different from
each other
in any aspect and while we know this all
the metrics all the domain KPIs we
talked about are on the session level we
measure the star rating which is given
per session we are measuring the
resolution rate which is given per
session so all the KPIs are on the
session level while if we introduce a
new feature to experts we are splitting
the traffic by the experts so what we
have here is some kind of samples that
are not actually independent from each
other all the sessions all the sessions
that belong to the same expert will have
some of these properties so we cannot
just think the data is independent so
what we did in this case we considered a
few options the first one is just group
by expert so instead of looking at every
session look at the average resolution
rate very specific expert problem here
is we are losing a lot of information
first we are losing all the energy
distribution for each expert with the
sessions he answered and second we are
getting to much less simple let's say in
one of our products we have about 200
experts and we have few thousand
sessions a day so we are getting from a
lot a lot of sessions to just 200
samples so again mainly losing
information if will grow by expert
and second one was stratified sampling
where you are
instead of randomizing all the experts
when you choose which one goes to the a
group and which one goes to the B group
instead of this for example if we want
to try to balance the resolution rate
then take the high level resolution rate
and the worst resolution rate and then
do the random spit within each group so
those are those methods the problem here
is we have multiple KPIs and being able
to answer all of those didn't went well
isn't a fight sampling and what we
eventually chose was going to more
complex models for this kind of
experiments where we experiment by
expert questions so what we did choose
is when we experiment by session which
introduced no issues since all the
sessions are independent from each other
then whenever it's a binomial we just
went to the simple Z test and we went to
bootstrapping whenever the distribution
is not binomial easy to to take from a
lot of different kpi's to others so it
was relatively easy test to choose and
when experimenting by experts where we
saw the issue where their samples are
not random and not independent then what
we did was using a few models so our
system mainly want to make sure we're
not harming KPI so we didn't find
anything wrong with maybe running a few
statistical tests for the same thing and
just raising a flag whenever something
is going wrong so we use both mixed
effect models and also a method we
developed here which is called which we
called simulations and I'll give like a
brief intro to what we did there
so what we wanted to do in this method
is first take advantage of the fact we
have a lot of sessions take advantage of
the fact that we have the best data for
every expert we are splitting the
experts 5050 or other portion but we do
know each expert what is what he have so
far
what is his metric so far and also same
as bootstrapping which is relatively
easy nowadays since computing power is
non-issue so also here being able to
compute computation wise simulate
running a lot of similar different
simulations and what we actually do is
randomly splitting all the experts to
groups I'm not talking about the
experiment part just about the
simulations running it a lot of
simulations splitting to a big group and
assume we are talking about the
resolution rate then for every group we
can measure there is a leash resolution
rate before the experiment and during
the experiment same for the big group
and like the new statistic we're using
the new value that we have at the end is
the difference between a and B group
before the experiment - their difference
while the experiment is running and
repeating this process multiple times
10,000 times in our case and using this
to build the distribution of this
statistic at the end we can take the
actual split of the experts from the
experiment look at the same statistic
and plot it for example what we got was
when running all the simulations that
was the distribution we got those are
the usual thresholds and the experiment
value resides over here meaning this
specific experiment did not introduce
any significant change to the resolution
rate
what is what sorry so this is the
distribution that's in the Instagram of
all the values that we created here in
those simulations we created multiple
simulations in creating a new value for
every random split and here we created
we plotted all those in a histogram so
the main reason we do measure it by the
session yes so we wanted to be able to
keep all the session values same is if
we would have used mixed effects model
so but we created a new statistic which
was the difference of the themes of the
groups before and after and just running
a lot of simulations give us the
distribution probability of how they
should behave and then we see how the
actual split of the experiment behave
regarding to this
or questions about it okay so future
work we still currently have in mind for
this system so the system is really as
we see it it's a platform like every
other platform which will iterate over
time grow over time evolve over time
so all the things we chose here are just
the first part of this journey and the
part where we want to also find
statistical testing methods where we saw
how to stop an experiment so we use the
simplest way we found which is just
changing the p-value but there are more
sophisticated methods currently so this
is one part we want to advance in the
future monitoring the current results
because it's first time we have this
kind of system we want to actually
monitor what we get as a results try to
understand where we need the
improvements what statistical test do we
need to maybe change improve or wherever
where we lack some information so just
monitoring the system also from the
statistics point of view
adding ability to a/b test against the
custom API currently we introduced a
change and we are testing it against all
the domain kpi's but sometimes teams
don't they want to make sure they are
not harming main KPI but they might want
to also try to improve some specific API
they have so also the ability to add
specific custom KPIs and having the
system report about it so a customer KPI
can just be what is my if they're
reporting an event they can just mention
what is the event that says conversion
never mind what conversion is and then
you can measure for two groups the
conversion against some new event
what why not having a control group
and just UI changes so currently we're
just sending mail having some web UI
first we'll bring more engagement to
this platform and make people talk about
it more so we find value in making it
not male and also be able to easily
collaborate between teams not just the
team that created an experiment we'll
get mail but everybody will easily can
go to a web and see the results see what
other teams are doing so those are the
most important thing we're thinking
about for next iterations
[Applause]